nous sommes en plateau avec le
vice-amiral Michel legaray bonjour merci
de répondre à nos questions votre CV est
impressionnant en retiendra notamment
que vous avez été aux commandes du porte
hélicoptère Jeanne d'Arc on est loin là
de la guerre express de l'opération
spéciale présentée par Vladimir Poutine
c'est une guerre qui va être longue à
votre avis où toi certainement
d'ailleurs on le voit bien dès le début
tous les indices montré que il espérait
faire une biskrie et puis en définitive
grâce à la résistance d'un peuple
ukrainien fabuleux qui est vraiment tout
à fait motivé par son président qui est
une vraie véritable surprise enfin tout
le monde le reconnaît ce peuple
ukrainien avec l'aide dont on va parler
peut-être plus tard l'aide de de
l'Occident et bien résiste d'une façon
absolument et horissante ce qui bien sûr
entraîne des pertes humaines incroyables
des des déplacements de population
incroyables que l'on chiffrait déjà
après 200 millions mais qui
effectivement
rend les les objectifs du
un peu difficile à atteindre
c'est difficile d'avoir des informations
sur l'armée russe mais certains médias
disent que l'armée manque de carburant
même de nourriture donc des problèmes
logistiques est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment que la dernière Poutine là
est pris un pot dépourvu alors tout
d'abord ça n'est pas impossible parce
que l'armée russe est une armée de de
conquête massive avec une possibilité de
ravitaillement massif avec des problèmes
logistiques on sait aussi que c'est une
armée qui n'est pas totalement bien
organisée enfin pas du moins selon les
schémas occidentaux modernes donc c'est
un peu difficile en plus ça il faut
occuper un pays de 44 millions
d'habitants et qui est plus grand que la
France donc il a fallu choisir des axes
de pénétration vous les avez tous en
mémoire et donc c'est compliqué pour lui
d'autant que la résistance ukrainienne a
été très forte à couper certains ponts
donc ce qui fait qu'on voit de très
longues files de
camions-citerne de temple de chars etc
immobilisé ce qui en ferait des cibles
fantastiques si le ciel n'était pas
désormais russe on parle aussi des états
d'âme des soldats russes est-ce que ça
peut jouer ou est-ce que c'est que ces
secondaires écoutez là je ne suis pas
dans je suis pas dans un chat russe et
je connais mal simplement ce dont nous
avons l'impression c'est que cette
armurerie s'est composée en grande
partie d'appeler et que les appeler ont
une assez forte influence en tout cas
lorsque leur corps revenait les
cercueils en zinc revenez dans les bras
de leur mère c'était très compliqué la
Russie a connu cela un Afghanistan par
exemple mais les pertes en Ukraine sont
10 fois supérieurs elles perdent
toujours en alliés sont 10 fois
supérieures à ce qu'il est reconnu un
Afghanistan ce qui fait que dans un
temps très très court il y a brutalement
des pertes et des retours alors bien sûr
tous les circuits d'information sont
coupés et verrouillés mais jusqu'à quand
vous parlez de cette résistance
résistance héroïque des
ils sont armés par les Occidentaux par
les Européens les Américains qui
devraient leur fournir des avions de
chasse est-ce que ça c'est un Game
changer est-ce que ça peut changer la
donne je n'en suis pas sûr je n'en suis
pas sûr
parmi les fournisseurs d'armes il y a
aussi beaucoup la Turquie et je pense
que la Turquie il va falloir en parler
un peu le projet que l'on que l'on
connaît que l'on a vu dans les médias en
tout cas d'aide de des États-Unis à la
Pologne pour fournir des avions paraît
un peu délicat à mettre en oeuvre bien
évidemment les pilotes ukrainien ne
peuvent mettre en oeuvre que des que des
matériels qu'ils connaissent c'est à
dire soit des Migs 29 soit des soukoys
seul la Pologne semble-t-il on a à sa
disposition Pologne qui a fermement dit
qu'elle ne les fournirait pas
ce qui fait que ces avions là qui ont
une avionique nouvelle qui ont été remis
au goût du jour ne sont pas forcément
très faciles à utiliser par des pilotes
Ukrainiens qui avaient l'habitude de des
anciens modèles donc c'est compliqué
nous firtons avec la ligne rouge ce qui
fait que autant comment l'OTAN l'OTAN et
surtout Poutine comment Poutine voit-il
la fourniture d'armes qui ne peut plus
prétendre qu'elles sont défensives un
avion de chasse c'est défensif offensif
vous savez bien et voyez bien qu'il y a
toute une hypocrisie dans cette dans ces
raisonnements là
défensive armes défensive pour les parle
Occident que Poutine semble encore
considérée comme des ordres défensives
puisque il n'a pas dit que la ligne
rouge était Francie mais mais le
fourniture d'avion de chasse là ça
changerait complètement donc
gamechangeur mais d'une façon qui n'est
pas prévisible qui est plutôt à risque
d'escalade risque d'escalade d'autant
que les Russes accusent les voisins de
l'Ukraine notamment la Roumanie de
fournir des finalement pour que les
avions Ukrainiens puissent voler est-ce
que ça vous semble probable non ça me
semble pas vraiment probable déjà que
les pays limitrophes que sont la Pologne
la Roumanie essentiellement sont des
points de passage pour les fournitures
d'armement donc voyez ce serait là aussi
une escalade et Poutine a dit que si des
aéroports polonais étaient utilisés
comme base arrière de l'avion qui
pourrait attaquer ses forces armées et
bien obligatoirement ce serait une ligne
rouge de franchie les lignes rouges on
savait ça veut dire que nous
deviendrions pardon kobelligérant
corbigérant nous deviendrons de fait
maintenant c'est ce que Poutine estime
ou non voilà c'est c'est ça c'est là
qu'elle problème
j'aimerais maintenant parler de la
bataille de Kiev on a vu notre envoyé
spécial à la limite de la capitale
ukrainienne les Russes sont en train
d'avancer au 12e jour de la guerre
comment vous expliquer que cette
capitale soit toujours tenue par les
Ukrainiens on parlait de la résistance
Poutine elle a les capacité de faire
tomber Kiev il y a des milliers de
soldats qui viennent de Biélorussie et
qui peuvent foncer converger vers la
capitale bien sûr qu'il a la capacité la
seule chose c'est que il espérait la
faire tomber d'elle-même comme un fruit
mûr et ça n'est pas ce qui s'est passé
c'est un armée qui venait directement
sur Kiev a été bloqué est encore bloqué
dans des dans des petites villes qui
commencent à être rasées d'ailleurs
puisque quand son avance s'affaiblit et
bien il y a plus que la solution de la
force brutale que connaissent très bien
les Russes donc cette avance effrénée
les autres les autres armées sont
freinés aussi celles qui doivent
entourer encerclé qui Ève par l'ouest à
une avancée beaucoup plus importante
maintenant qui avait une agglomération
extrêmement vaste c'est une
conglomération c'est assez
extraordinaire plus difficile et si vous
entrez dans une bataille de rue là ce
sont plus tellement les chars c'est la
valeur des combattants c'est le
combattivité ce sont les armes dont ils
sont dotés c'est leur organisation et
leur morale qui va être essentiel et les
Russes connaissent très bien qui est
ils connaissent parfaitement l'Ukraine
mais ils ont des amis moi je parlais
avec un russe de la connaissance illisé
que ses frères et sœurs étaient acquises
il se téléphone tout le temps ce qui
fait que les médias si vous voulez même
si les médias généraux qui arrosent tout
un pays ne sont pas pertinents il y a
aussi tout ce tissu de téléphonique et
de relations personnelles et puis vous
avez parlé de l'armée qui est en Belarus
il y a là un tiers ou un quart des
armées russes qui est là 50000 hommes
sur pied de guerre qui n'a pas bougé
alors il semble bien que cette armée là
soit destinée envahir l'Ouest ou à
couper des communications dans l'ouest
de l'Ukraine en particulier vers la
Pologne comment est-ce que vous voyez la
bataille de Kiev qui s'annonce ça sera
une guérilla urbaine urbaine plus que
une guerre dans les airs puisque lave la
lumière pout n'a pas intérêt à raser ok
la capitale on ne sait pas où est son
intérêt veuillez tout le monde dit que
c'est un joueur d'échec en fait on a
bien l'impression que en ce moment c'est
plutôt un joueur de poker et c'est un
joueur de poker qui joue sur en
simultané sur plusieurs plateaux
différents il joue contre l'Ukraine ou
l'Ukraine c'est le plateau peut-être
mais il joue aussi contre les États-Unis
contre l'OTAN contre l'Europe n'oublions
pas la Turquie qui a une position tout à
fait particulière dans l'échiquier et
puis aussi la Chine qui bien qu'elle est
maintenue son soutien semble-t-il avec
la Russie est un est un soutien comme
l'Accord de soutien lependu ils sont
fragiles bien sûr tout l'Extrême-Orient
russe leur temps les bras avec tous ces
minerais et ses ressources donc un jour
ou l'autre Poutine risque de se
retrouver quel que soit
le devenir de son entreprise en
Ukraine risque de se retrouver en face
de la Chine